IT 아키텍처의 진화 1990년대부터 현재까지 얘기해 보도록 하겠습니다.
1990년대 CS 시대라고 표현을 했는데 C는 클라이언트이고요, S는 서버입니다.
그래서 PC가 나오고, 사실 이때 윈도우 95, 98, 윈도우 98, NT, 윈도우 2000 이런 OS들이
쭉 나올 당시였어요. 윈도우라는 게 95년도에 뭐 그전에도 있었지만 버전이 있었지만
보통 일반인들이 쓰는 버전은 95부터 좀 쓰는 편이었고 98을 많이 사용했죠.
그렇다면 이때 이제 PC는 이미 대중화가 됐을 것이고 이때 이제 중앙서버라고 해서
중앙에 서버를 두고 단마리 접속해서 쓰는 형태
이런 식의 형태가 이때 아키텍처였었고요.
그래서 윈도우 95, RDBMS라는 것들이 IT 아키텍처의 줄을 이뤘습니다.
RDBMS는 여기에 데이터베이스를 별도로 만들어서 데이터만 주로 담깨끔
이런 식의 아키텍처가 형성이 된 거죠.
서버의 형태에서 서버인데 서버의 데이터를 다 저장할 수 있거든요.
우리도 지금 노트북을 쓰든 컴퓨터를 쓰든 거기에 데이터가 다 저장되어 있잖아요.
별도의 데이터베이스를 구축에 쓰지 않죠. 서버도 마찬가지였습니다.
그런데 데이터만 집중적으로 모아서 관리한다라는 것들이 형성이 된 거죠.
그래서 디비가 따로 만들어지는 아주 초창기의 형태.
그러면서 이때 2000년대, 2000년대라고 하면 이렇게 표현도 하지만
닷컴 시대라는 표현도 하고 이 이후에 닷컴 버블이라는 것도 충격적으로 다가왔죠.
이게 뭐냐면 닷컴이나 닷컴 버블은 전부 다 웹을 말합니다.
따따따라고 표현하고 월드와이드 웹이라고 하는데 웹이라고도 했죠.
월드와이드 웹 전세계를 연결하는 그런 웹이다.
그것이 웹시대.
이 때 Http 프로토컬로 서버들과 클란트 서버 간의 데이터를 주고받게 되는 웹시대.
기존까지만 해도 통신망은 있었어요. PC통신도 있었고.
근데 이때 인터넷 시대가 된 거죠.
웹 시대에는 아키텍처적으로는 웨바스 디비가 대표적인 3티어 구조고
요 때 이제 어플리케이션도 많이 발전합니다.
웹이 단순히 정적인 이미지나 텍스터만 보여주는 것이 아니라
데이터베이스를 별도로 두고 데이터를 가져와서 보여준다든지
이렇게 중간에 웹 웹 어플리케이션들이 많이 발전을 하면서
여기에 실제 프로그램들을 올리는 웹 어플리케이션 서버가 등장을 해서
이런 구조 3티어 구조로 만들어지고
램스테그는 이제 리눅스 아파치, 마이애스쿠엘, PHP 이런 것들로
웹 사이트를 만들었던 당시다라는 겁니다.
그리고 2010년도 좀에서 아이폰이라든가 갤럭시 이런 것들로
모바일이 대세가 됐죠.
그 전까지만 해도 PC기반 인터넷 웹 이런 거였다면
이때는 이제는 모바일로 모바일 앱들이 막 발전하고 그 팽창했죠.
이때 한 번 또 뭔가 IT의 붐이 온 거죠.
닷컴처럼 모바일죠.
클라우드 시장 이런 것들이 왔고
이때 등장한 게 이제 AWS.
원래 아마존이라는 책을 인터넷으로 팔던 회사가
이 자원들을 활용하기 위해서 활용하면서 서비스로
자원을 서비스로 쓰기 시작한 게
인프라이저 서비스, 아이아스, 사스 이런 것들이
이후에 나오게 된 거죠.
그래서 인프라를 서비스로 제공하는
그런 개념이 등장하는 클라우드.
그리고 스마트폰 비롯해서 모바일 이런 것들이
굉장히 각각받고 빅데이터라는 키워드가
굉장히 많이 회자됐던.
빅데이터가 결국은 또 AI로 좀 연결이 되죠.
그때 아키텍처는 그때부터 슬슬 나온 게
MSA, DevOps, agile 이런 것들이 나왔습니다.
MSA는 서비스가 엄청나게
초대형 서비스를 많이 나왔잖아요.
그 넷플릭스도 그렇고
그런데부터 MSA라는 아키텍처를 이용하면서
작은 서비스를 나눠서 서비스를 해서
리스크를 줄이고 문제점들을 부분으로
전체 문제가 되지 않도록 처리하는
구조의 아키텍처들이 나온 거죠.
그리고 이제는 다 알고 있는 AI,
채치, PT.
그 벌써 3, 4년, 4, 5년 되는 시점이 된 거잖아요.
그리고 초연결.
그러니까 이게 소셜이라든가 이런 걸로
모든 것의 데이터를 다 연결되고
마이 데이터 이런 식으로 해서
모든 데이터에 연동이 되어지고
AI에서 AI로 서비스를 만드는 시대가 된 거죠.
이때 이제 GPU, NVIDIA를 비롯해서
GPU의 발전, 하드웨어도 같이 발전한 거죠.
하드웨어 발전으로 인해서 AI까지 왔는데
기존 빅 데이터도 하드웨어 발전을 왔고
클라우드도 하드웨어 발전을 왔는데
그 하드웨어 발전으로 인해서
또 AI가 더 견고해지고
AI가 발전을 하기 위해서 하드웨어가 또 발전되는
그런 선순환이 되면서
엄청나게 IT는 초고속 성장을 하고 있는
그런 단계까지 왔습니다.
그래서 이거는 아주 기술적인 얘기라기보다는
전체의 흐름에 대한 이해를 위해서
한번 짚어본 내용이고요.
아키텍처적으로는 조금씩 바뀌었는데
지금까지도 MSA 아키텍처라든가
이런 거는 여전히 유지되고 있는 상황이고
다만 이제 AI가 나오면서
이제는 어떤 식으로 아키텍처를 구성하는 게 좋은지
그런 식의 고민이 많이 이루어지는 단계라고 보여집니다.
또 유용한 내용으로 찾아뵙겠습니다.
감사합니다.